trans acceptance and lgbt acceptance in
general
is on the decline for the first time in
decades and i think there's a reason for
that i think people
are finding that like i said it's too
hard to keep up with the ever-changing
rules for how you're supposed to talk
walk interact speak about certain things
how you can't speak about certain things
if you have a certain identity or skin
color
it's just too much for people
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry
i'm francis foster i'm constantine
kitchen and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is an american
youtuber blair white welcome to
trigonometry
hey guys thank you so much for having me
i'm a big fan of your channel so it's
really cool to be here
that's very kind of you to say actually
i think when i first joined youtube i
remember watching some of your stuff so
it's very much
a mutual feeling and we really
appreciate you coming on
it's awesome to have you here listen
before we get into all the juicy stuff
and there's a lot of juicy stuff to get
into in the last few weeks
uh just tell everybody here in the uk
people may not be familiar with with you
and your backstory
who are you how are you where you are
what has been your journey through life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
right so like you mentioned i'm a
youtuber which
has it's definitely an unexpected event
in my life becoming a youtuber i never
sought out intending to have this be a
career or a job
or any big part of my life i put up a
video
about five years ago ranting about my
experience on my college campus being
overrun
by extreme liberalism and i expected
maybe seven people to watch it and i
woke up and it had thousands of views
and ever since then my life has been
completely different
um you know i am a trans woman i often
try to bring a different perspective to
trans issues
on youtube because i find that there is
a serious lack of nuance in the
conversation from other
trans people on the platform and also
trans activists in general i'm often
described as sort of the anti-trans
activist
i definitely you know advocate for trans
people but
in a much different way than the
traditional sort of extreme leftist
activists that you guys maybe have a
caricature of in your mind
um i am a republican so i'm known for
that and people think that's a bit of a
contradiction being trans and republican
but i could go off for
days about how it's not uh yeah so
that's that's kind of
me in a nutshell right now yeah well
we'll get into a lot of the stuff you
mentioned there
uh but the first thing just for me i'd
like to say i'm very jealous of you
because our youtube experience was
exactly the opposite we uploaded our
first video expecting it to get a lot of
views and it got
absolute bugger all uh so it's good that
you had the opposite experience
but listen of course that the trans
issue is heavily uh
heavily talked about at the moment we've
talked about it with many many people in
the past but we wanted to get your
taken because i saw we saw a video you
did about this
trans-racial korean guy so
yeah uh so can you explain to us i mean
this is something that a lot of us have
been warning about like if you can
self-identify as whatever you want why
can't you be
a dif why can't let me ask you why can't
you be korean if you want to be
well i so i did a video about this
individual um
which i believe is a troll and it's kind
of a brilliant troll if you think about
it because
um his name's ali london he's really
playing into
the rules set by the woke left they have
completely
attempted to remove any and all science
behind being transgender or being
transsexual as a proper term
um and they've made all identities valid
so if all identities are valid then that
one kind of has to be valid too
um i of course disagree that it's valid
i don't think there's any science behind
being transracial any sort of like you
know
happening in the womb that we see with
some people who are transsexual so i
think it's different
um but i also think that the left
doesn't get to play it both ways it
doesn't get to say all identities are
valid
it doesn't get to say that there are
thousands and thousands of genders and
you can change your
your gender and your biological sex but
you can't change
your race and it's interesting that you
say you can't change your race
what i can't believe i'm asking this
question why can't you change your race
if people think that you can change your
sex
well that's the thing people do think
that you can change your sex but i'm
definitely not one of those people i
think that biological sex
is it is what it is you know despite
being a trans woman which is the
cultural word for the place i hold in
society i
am absolutely a biological male i was
born that way i will die that way i
wasn't assigned at birth
it was a biological sex that was
observed and recorded at birth
um so yeah i mean i'm not playing by the
rules in the first place so i don't
think i have to justify like
why you can change your race you
definitely you don't have to you
definitely don't have to justify but
take us through the logical sequence
of the difference right because to a lot
of people who don't know much about this
issue which is pretty much everybody
right
probably us included to a large extent
this has all been kind of
i remember we interviewed people on our
channel and i'd be like well why can't
we just all be like polite
right you know people people want to
identify as well and they're not
quite hurting anyone again our research
since
and a lot of the stories that come out
recently have disabused us of that
notion on some things but
why what's the difference between being
transsexual
and being transracial quo unquote well
being trans
uh transsexual rather has a medical
history behind it um it's been recorded
throughout history there are people who
for biological reasons whether it's
feminization or masculinization in the
womb
deal with gender identity i don't think
that it makes them the opposite sex i
think that it makes them
struggling with their current sex and so
i think when you have things like gender
dysphoria which up until recently was
classified as a
mental disorder um you know these are
things that are found in nature
whereas as far as i know there's no
equivalent to gender dysphoria racial
dysphoria or
um you know something that happens in
the womb to make someone feel a
different race so
i do think it's different in that sense
um but
what's interesting is you know i
personally disagree with the
declassification of gender dysphoria as
a mental disorder i don't think there's
anything wrong with saying that it is a
mental disorder i think especially
in this era of trying to destigmatize
mental disorders
um it's the best descriptor for it i
think that if you're born with
sort of a misalignment mentally with
your biological sex and your sense of
being and that that is something that
negatively impacts your mental health
that's a mental disorder
um and for me you know i don't see any
issue with calling anxiety mental
disorder with calling depression mental
disorder so why would gender dysphoria
be one
so i think the primary difference
obviously between trans racial and
transsexual
is that there are biological vehicles to
take someone to
transition and struggle with their
gender and blair what does it say about
our culture
when this particular individual gets
such traction
and it becomes a talking point whereas
ten years ago we would have looked at
this person
and thought well there is clearly
something not quite right there
well i think it's because like i said
before
like there is this new narrative that
all identities are valid so
you know i think that a lot of people
saw this as something funny something
that was like a troll at least i did
um and like i said it's brilliant in the
sense that it it reveals
the hypocrisy of the rules of the woke
left which is that you have to
accept it of course they're not they're
attacking him
but it's hypocritical and we talk about
the rules of the woke left
could number one could you just go
through them for us and number two and
this is a question i really wanted to
ask you
is do those do these rules help you
help me personally absolutely not uh no
if anything they make my life my life a
living hell uh
so asking me to recite the woke rules i
don't know they change every five
seconds and if you don't keep up you're
cancelled so who the [ __ ] knows
but um you know it's ideas like trans
women or women
without any meaningful delineation
between the two it's rules like
um all white people are racist it's
rules like um
i don't know you're ableist if you say
the word [ __ ] like it's just it's a
lot it's a lot it's too much to keep up
with
it it very much contradicts human nature
in the ways that we interact with
each other um and frankly as a trans
person you mentioned does it help you
absolutely not it does the opposite in
the sense that
it actually makes people feel like they
have to walk around on eggshells around
me
which isn't a good feeling for me you
know i'm someone who's very sociable
i have an active social life and i hate
when i feel
that moment where someone thinks that
they might say something that offends me
or they might say something that's out
of line because
even if they did it's not a big deal and
i would rather have a real conversation
about it rather than
you know get upset and make them feel
bad about themselves so um
the trans community and the activists
that they tend
to propel to the top and those rising
voices that sort of scream over the rest
of us more sane ones in the
community um they are the craziest of
the bunch and they do way more harm than
good i often say they only know how to
shoot themselves in the foot
so they definitely you know trans
acceptance and lgbt acceptance in
general
is on the decline for the first time in
decades and i think there's a reason for
that i think people
are finding that like i said it's too
hard to keep up with the ever-changing
rules for how you're supposed to talk
walk interact speak about certain things
how you can't speak about certain things
if you have a certain identity or skin
color
it's just too much for people and i do
expect a pendulum
swing eventually um
but it's not really i guess it's still a
little far off
well this is what i was going to ask you
about because i don't know i was
actually quite looking forward to the
olympics in tokyo because
i thought that you know the conversation
about trans women and sport
uh was going to get a bit of a different
perspective on it when you see the
visuals
of active competition we're not sure if
they're going to go ahead
uh do you think stuff like that will
start to bring it to
to the four to people that this is more
than just about kind of
respecting people's pronouns there's an
actual real-life consequence to some of
the stuff
i hope so you know when i saw that um
there were trans athletes that were
going to the olympics i was upset
because you know i've taken a lot of
heat for this but i'm not someone who
supports trans women
in women's sports i think that almost
all of the time it's highly unfair
um i think that that's just a very
simple biological reality that
biological males have just a list of
advantages even if they are on estrogen
um
however then i kind of like i kind of
agree with you
i was like well maybe it's a good thing
because the overwhelming amount of
people who argue
in defense of trans women and women
sports they have a completely different
picture in their mind they probably
don't even know any trans people they're
just trying to be virtuous
um it's an issue that they just want to
be
nice about frankly they don't want to
hurt anyone's feelings so they do
support it
however they're just stunning visuals
i'm sure you guys have seen them they're
just like
the best pictures that are almost a
parody
of like trans uh track
what's the word people who play track i
don't know competitors trans athletes
okay trans athletes whatever
um clearly i don't know anything about
sports uh
like just looming over
their biological female competitors like
beating them wiping them the [ __ ] out
and it's like how can anyone look at
those pictures and be like oh yeah
that's fair
like it's a joke um you know so
again that's one of the things i get the
most hate for that i don't support it
but
i don't i don't really see why being
included in sports is a human right it's
not like you're being denied housing or
food or a job
it's it's it's sports it's a very good
point blair
do you don't you think the problem is is
that most of the people
who watch this will share your point of
view
and they will have complete empathy for
your position and will want you to live
as full of life
as as possible and for you to be happy
as possible
but they don't feel that they can say
trans
women shouldn't be in female sports
because
that's a way to get ruined cancelled
have your career shut down etc etc
absolutely i'm trans and i get attacked
for it so imagine if someone
who isn't trans is saying it you know
what i mean uh
but i do find that
most people feel that way like because
i've done videos on this topic
i suddenly have people reaching out that
i know in real life that aren't
political at all that don't have any
you know necessarily political
persuasion who are like
i've never been able to say it you know
i have people who play sports like
good example um my mom called me and
said that my nephew
had two trans athletes playing in i
think it was like tennis or something at
their high school
and that they're just kind of like
demolishing everyone and no one's
allowed to talk about it
like this is just something that people
tend to suspend
their knowledge of how the real world
works to argue in favor of
um which doesn't work and you say it
doesn't work but eventually
you can suspend your real-life knowledge
of the world
but eventually the world is going to
come and slap you in the face as i've
found many times to my cost
right so that's why
that's why i'm actually excited about um
those athletes
going to the olympics because i think
that when people see that uh
juxtaposition
um like laurel hubbard for example you
guys know who that one is like
come on like
if you want to talk about like track and
maybe baseball or something it's like
okay let's have the debate but like
weightlifting something that's
completely upper body
driven and complete like come on it's so
obvious
but you know it's it's one of those
things that i think people have to see
to
have their minds changed about do you
have a website
or do you plan to have a website well if
you do
then easy dns are the company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns of rock
solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com forward slash
triggered
and use our promo code which is of
course triggered as well
and you will get fifty percent off with
the initial purchase
sign up for their newsletter access of
easy
that tells you everything you need to
know about technology
privacy and censorship blair and you
alluded to the fact that this issue is
political and the truth is i guess we
probably wouldn't be talking about if it
was if
it wasn't a constant thing that was
talked about in the political way why
can you explain this to me
why is this issue political at all
well because i think that um
transgenderism
has become a political issue which it
really shouldn't um
i always argue in favor for the fact
that it should be treated as a medical
a neurological issue completely
um but there is this movement to
demedicalize
what being trans is to say that you
don't need gender dysphoria to be trans
to say that
you know there are no biological
differences between male and female
which is a contradiction for why they
keep allowing and pushing for underage
children to get surgeries
but um you know when you remove
any meaningful way to diagnose something
all you have left is the politics of it
and
that's what's unfortunate that there are
real trans people who are
who have found themselves becoming this
political football being thrown back and
forth between these two sides that
frankly both sides always get it wrong
uh so
you know maybe it's a pipe dream maybe
it's impossible but we have to attempt
to de-politicize the issue
we have to attempt to regain control of
the narrative that it is a medical issue
in my opinion because
that's historically how it was always
treated you know there was a time before
this hyper wokeness that you know maybe
not everyone really knew what being
trans was but everyone kind of had this
um
underlying knowledge in the back of
their head that there are some people
that want to be women some people that
want to be men when they are not
and that those people have surgeries and
have hormones and that it's like a
medical thing
and frankly i find that things were much
less fiery heated and contentious when
that was sort of the overall consensus
that i was like oh yeah it's a medical
thing some people do even if people
thought it was weird they saw it as that
now it's become this hyper-political
issue that
is just toxic for everyone and it is
toxic for everyone
do you think part of the problem is and
you've alluded to it earlier in the
interview saying that
you know people want to do the right
thing do you think people are conflating
the gay rights issue
in the early 80s and what the struggle
that gay that gay people had
to trans people in 2021 and they just
don't want to make the same mistakes
really
i think that that's part of it i think
that there's this
need to be on the right side of history
um whatever the current right side is
perceived to be
or correct side i should say um
and yeah it's ju we live in an
environment where
if you are not seen as 1 000
accepting 1 000 on board with the
current narrative
and in terms of being progressive you
almost can't even live in polite society
even in red
states even in places that maybe there
are more conservatives because
these major corporations that employ
people you don't have the freedom to say
how you really feel about things even if
it is something as
you know i don't think it should be
controversial at all to say that
sports should be you know segregated by
biological sex
but it's become something that is i
don't think it's controversial at all to
say
that 12 year olds should not be going on
hormones before they even hit puberty
and are capturing themselves and
removing their ability to have children
that's something people don't often talk
about when it comes to trans kids by the
way
when you transition as an early teenager
or a child
you can't have kids later in life which
i think is a
it's a whole other topic we don't have
to get into that right now but um
you know long story short people don't
feel like they can say how they really
feel
well you bring up children and this is
something we've talked a lot about we've
had
uh marcus evans who's a whistleblower
from the tavistock clinic here in the uk
that was involved in a lot of this stuff
uh i correct me if i'm wrong about your
own biography but i think you
you you said you came out as transit
transsexual at the age of about 20 right
yes
but but you had felt gender dysphoria
from childhood
yes my earliest memories in life were
that of gender dysphoria that's why i
feel so strongly about it being a
biological issue
i think if something is present at four
years old
and persists your entire life there's
something
neurological or biological about that so
right so where i'm leading you is would
it not have been better for you to
transition as a kid so you could have
just been grown up being
a transsexual woman and you know from a
girl from a young age and go through
that
whole period of life uh with
with the with the gender that you now
are
i don't think so i think that if i had
gone on hormone replacement therapy
as a teenager maybe let's say 13 14
years old
i don't think i would have been ready
for that i think that oftentimes unless
you go through
transition you don't really understand
how extreme of a thing it is for
your mental for your physical for
everything emotional
um and i just don't think that a young
teenager is ready for that
um i know that i would have not handled
it very well at all you know i
i did not have my life figured out at 13
none of us
do and i think that adding in um
drugs and surgeries would have probably
messed me up worse i think that
i was meant to be exactly who i am now i
think that
um i don't regret a single thing along
my journey i don't regret my transition
or when it happened
um and i think that it also helped me
give it helped to give me a healthier
perspective
on these issues as well um
i think that two things can be true at
once i think that
there are people that transition very
young and it's kind of like a
luck of the draw like some of them are
happy as adults some of them are not you
know i've spoken to many people
young people who are d transitioners
which is people who transition and then
regret it and attempt to go back um
and so as long as it's sort of this
roll of the dice then i don't support
children transitioning
don't you think this is why this is
where the whole thing might unravel
even with the thing like women's sports
people be like you know what fair enough
you know trans women and women they can
take part
they can be a shock putter they can win
the gold in the olympics it doesn't
russians have been doing it for years
exactly but
when it comes to people's kids and you
start messing with their kids
that's when the whole thing is going to
unravel
and people quite rightly are going to
get very angry about it
yes absolutely and this is the main
disconnect the biggest disconnect
between the trans community
and the rest of the world you know i
find that the trans community is often
so insular
and so hive-minded that they don't
understand how they're coming across
to the general population and one thing
the general population
doesn't quite like is when you mess with
kids when you're drugging kids
when you're giving kids surgeries and
when you're if you are perceived to be a
threat to children
your movement's really over so um
that's why i fight so hard against it
because i don't want the trans community
or trans people
individuals who are trans to be seen as
a danger to society or children
um same thing with women you know
there's a big divide between
um some feminists and trans people and
i think you guys will cover that as well
and interviewed certain feminists on
your channel that feel that way
and for me it's very hard for me to not
understand where they're coming from
because
you have situations like in los angeles
recently
um a trans person allegedly went into a
nude spa and
was pre-op meaning that they had male
genitals
and it is around women and children and
i think that that's absolutely
disgusting
and if i was you know a biological woman
reading that story i would be like
i'm done i'm done caring about this this
is awful
so i think that there is a really big
pr problem with the trans community um
and if i had it my way i would change
almost all of the messaging and
almost all of the things that we are
allegedly fighting for
but isn't part of the problem as well is
that word community
when the reality is you know trans
people look at like take you for example
you know you supported tr you voted for
trump in the
2016 election i don't know if
sorry twice so you voted for trump twice
right okay you're a right of center
conservative trans woman the reality is
there is no trans community it's just
different people
who have gender dysphoria and then they
live their lives as they choose isn't
that part of the problem
that we just think of trans people and
gay people as this homogenous blob
yes you're absolutely right and even i
fall
into that saying words like trans
community when in reality we aren't a
monolith
you know um and i think that there are
so many more people in the trans
community that agree with me than people
realize
um i think that as we've sort of been
touching on
kind of the biggest theme of this
episode is like people just don't feel
like they can say how they really feel
and that includes trans people
you know oftentimes they don't feel like
they're gonna get a community from maybe
right wingers or people that aren't in
the trans community so
they're going to go along with at least
publicly whatever the current narrative
of the community
is um but i mean i can tell you
um i often go to bars in the lgbt part
of
west hollywood and i can't walk more
than two feet without
trans people coming up to me hugging me
saying they agree with me saying they
can never say
that they agree with me but they do but
then they see how badly i get treated
and they don't want that
um so
it's interesting i think that people
should start to see people more as
individuals um
but that's so hard when you know we are
so divided amongst
groups and labels and i think we just
have to work to get out of that the best
we can
um well you talked about the messaging
and how it felt up to you you changed
almost everything that's what i was
really going to ask you
what is what is a healthy way of
approaching this whole this whole
conversation that we've been having
hmm i think if i had just my
magic wand and i could change the
mindset of the of the community i would
i would say we need to absolutely halt
surgeries puberty blockers and hormones
for our children i think that it's such
a
vast injustice that there are so many
kids right now i mean
if you even look up the word
detransition or detransitioner on
youtube
it's just like the number of young kids
is growing every day uploading their
videos
and they're going viral for it so it's
not like it can be ignored it's just kid
after kid after kid
after kids saying they got looped into
believing they're trans by their peer
group or by
the internet and now that they've
permanently altered their bodies they
realized
it was a regret and i can't imagine
anything more tragic so
um stop with the kid stuff
and uh i think that we need to return to
viewing it as a medical issue
um we need to continue to destigmatize
mental health and mental disorders
and go back to admitting that gender
dysphoria is a disorder
if like i said my earliest memories in
life for gender dysphoria i was four
years old feeling like i didn't want to
be called he
and i didn't know why i was four years
old wanting to play with the girls and
not knowing why
i was four years old being uncomfortable
with my male name and not knowing why
um what i know now is that often times
after that's the result of feminization
in the womb
which is not part of my not in my
control um
and so when you have that span the
entirety of your life it's hard for me
to not view it as a disorder when it
causes distress
um i think that we need to stop with
ridiculous narratives like it's
transphobic to not date trans people i
think we need to stop with
with all of it i think all those things
do such harm
to actual trans people and it creates
such a backlash that
i would rather focus on so much else
and you say you would rather you'd
rather focus on so much else and we've
talked about the politics
of it but why can't you be a trans woman
and
be a trump supporter why do you have to
be on the left
why can't you be on the right and want
small government
is that so crazy right right
and it always gets me when people
pretend as if it's some sort of
contradiction as if
the only thing i'm supposed to care
about is being trans
as if the lens in which i view every
political
geopolitical issue is supposed to be the
lens of being trans like what the [ __ ]
does being trans have to do with my view
on the economy
with the size and role of the government
with foreign policy
with who i'm voting for as governor like
i mean i live in los angeles i live in a
blue city and a blue state
and i've been miserable under democratic
leadership
what does that have to do with me being
trans i don't quite know
well i guess the argument sorry to jump
in but i guess the argument if i
vocalize the undercurrent that underpins
all of this is
people on the right are bigots
and you are part of a group that is
likely to be targeted by bigots
that's i think the message right right
and
um it's interesting someone actually
messaged me yesterday and said why would
you be
you know on the right when they don't
actually like you
which is like i feel like if people on
the right didn't like me i wouldn't have
all the success i've had over the years
i mean
hundreds of millions of views from a
primarily conservative audience
um gotten to travel the country speaking
to groups of thousands of young people
that are conservatives like
i'm not quite confident in saying that
the right just hates me but even if they
did even if
every single conservative person looked
at me
as something evil or bad or didn't like
me because i'm trans
well given that even if every single one
i'm not part i don't
vote based on how other people feel or
vote
i'm not part i'm not i don't vote
republican because i want to be part of
some group or because i want to be part
of some tribe
i vote republican because it most
closely not perfectly but most closely
aligns with how i think the government
should be ran
it's really that simple i think people
that seek community in political spaces
find themselves following narratives and
groupthink rather than thinking for
themselves
um so someone messaged me asking me why
would you be republican when they all
hate you
and point into like one republican who
said something nasty about me
some completely irrelevant commentator
and i responded
wow that's amazing thank you for
enlightening me i'm not a democrat
because this one republican said
something
nasty about me this completely erases
the years of
thousands of death threats and doxing
and personal attacks from democrats
thank you
so if i mean if you want to gauge where
i get the most love from
it's going to be the right so and we're
talking about this do you not think that
a part of it
is because the left the democrats want
to see you as a victim
and you obviously don't identify that
way and as a result of that
it really [ __ ] pisses them off if i'm
being honest
right but you know what it pisses me off
more that people insist that i am some
sort of victim that it's something
controversial for me to say i am not a
victim
i'm a young successful i'm beautiful i'm
an entrepreneur i
live my life on my own terms i've come
from nothing and created everything that
i have now which is an incredibly
blessed life i am so far from a victim
i know people who are not trans who
suffer 10 times more than me i know
people who
are black who suffer less than more than
me it's all about
being an individual um and
i think that this push to view people as
a collective or as a group or as
other trans people are suffering so that
means all trans people our victims are
suffering is so toxic and i think that
it's a very self-defeating
lens to view the world i think that when
you view the world through this
adversarial lens and you see
like cis people or i hate that word but
cis people or white people or straight
people as the enemy
you're never gonna get ahead in life and
so it seems to me that
what i'm arguing for is so much
healthier for the trans community to
believe in which is self-reliance
independence entrepreneurship
and just killing it like just go out and
life and kill it that's what you have to
do
um being trans doesn't hold you back if
anything
being trans has created more
opportunities for me it's just different
doors
it's not any less doors that are open
for you because you're trans it's just
different doors and you have to learn
to walk through them and navigate
with the best of the cards that you're
dealt and
i'm gonna i want to ask you a question
why don't you like the term sis
because that's the term that really
really gets on
sell women's kids but that's not
appropriate that's a south londonism
um i just think that it's um
a bit useless for one and i think that
as long as there are enough people who
are
cis who say they don't want to be called
cis if we're living in this world when
people
don't want to be labeled things that
don't want to be labeled then i just try
not to use it you know um
i think that it's just fine enough to
say
trans versus biological women or not
trans or trans
um i think that you don't have to
classify 99.8 percent of the population
or whatever i think that
it's just annoying it's more so annoying
i don't hate it i don't have some
passion at burning hate more but i just
think it's annoying
yeah and listen i'm gonna ask you
something
kind of provocative in a way do you get
bored talking about this stuff are you
bored that we're asking you about trans
for the first half an hour of this
interview no it's not that i'm bored
um at all i'm totally happy to talk
about these issues because
if i'm not talking about it in this way
i don't really know any other
influencers that are
and so i think that it's important um
but if i'm being honest there is a bit
of a disconnect between
like the things that i talk about online
and the things that
make up my real life and that are
important to me in real life like in my
real life
me being trans is it's never an issue
it's not a topic of conversation with my
friends and family it's not something
that
i walk down the street and start having
a conversation with someone about being
trans so
it it is primarily exclusive to
online discourse so it's never that i'm
bored it's just
that you know in my real life there are
such
i guess bigger issues like [ __ ] rise
of communism in the united states like
that's that's like almost more so where
my head is at most of the time but
you know i do i will never not talk
about trans issues as long as
no one else is willing to talk about
them like this you know there are
you know maybe 100 other trans youtubers
and
almost none of them say the things i say
about trans stuff so
until the majority are saying it i'll
continue i'll continue saying it the
reason i ask you is uh
from a kind of youtuber's perspective
you've been incredibly successful
with with your channel and i was
wondering whether you feel somewhat
trapped by the audience that you've
built by talking about this
issue when you really you want to be
talking about other sides of the
you know you talk about some of your
political views do you ever feel a bit
like you'd be quite
keen to break out of that a little bit
or do you take your audience with you
how do you feel about that
sometimes you know um
i think one of the things that i have
done well is i've made my audience care
about me as a person and not just the
issues i talk about so
um you know on my channel you'll find
personal videos you'll find
um videos where i call out you know
child predators i'm posting one of those
later today
um i guess sometimes i feel like i'm
like forced to talk about trans issues
on my channel but at the same time like
i said i don't mind it and also
um i think that's kind of a common thing
with all youtubers i think
all youtubers i've ever known feel a
sort of pressure to
give their audience the content that
they come to expect from them
and not necessarily everything they want
to talk about so if i had it my way
you know i'm like fascinated by space
i'd be making videos about space
and about potential life in the upper
atmosphere of venus
uh but you know that's not the world we
live in and so
i reserve that for maybe instagram
stories or twitter
[ __ ] like that hey kkk do you like
feeling
silky and smooth like a sexual dolphin
never talk to me again what if i told
you that manscape to brought out a new
and improved lawn mower
3.0 that allows you to be fresh
and trim for the ladies down below
i'm married the last time i was fresh
and trimmed down below jimmy savile
was a respected children's entertainer
i'm going to ignore that the lawnmower
has a cutting edge ceramic blade which
reduces the risk of having an accident
where you least want an accident my bank
account no you idiot
you know los huevos oh right
plus it's waterproof which means you can
groom in the shower
and it has an led light so you can
really get an
accurate and precise trim excellent
sounds great what's the battery like 90
minutes
so you can do your whole area in about
seven recharges to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get twenty percent off with
free shipping just use our code which is
of course
trigger 2-0 that is trigger 2-0 that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscaped.com and use our code
which is of course tricker20
your boss will thank you excellent
and bleh do you sometimes feel
i'm going to level with you the more
we've gone through this pandemic
the more i've become a conspiracy
theorist when i started this place
yeah you know you know that was that's
what happens when you've got access to
weed
and occur a laptop plus 24-hour internet
do you know what i mean
but no but do you not feel sometimes
that you're being used as a political
pawn
the whole trans thing that you know to
people so people get riled up
whilst other things are happening that
are actually far more important and
affect
every single person on this planet
yeah i feel like it often is a
distraction
um it's not to say these issues
don't matter because i think there are
you know real life consequences
but right i would be lying if i said i
cared more about it than you know the
entire world being locked down
over a virus with a 99.7 survival rate
um with like more and more of my
generation identifying as communists
with cuba you know rising up for the
first time and then the mainstream media
completely covering it up by
saying that it's about the virus when
it's about communism
um you know i think that there are more
pressing threats
um but i also think the culture war
matters and i think that
you know to
have more of a position of power for our
side to implement change when it comes
to bigger threats like communism and
lockdowns and all of that
you have to win the culture award and
why is that blow
why why do you have to win the culture
well because
the oh sorry because the long and short
of it is people vote on
the cultural war most people don't have
the time to educate themselves on
any sort of real substantive policy on
the economy on foreign policy
and so while all those things can be
great and the right can rail about them
all day and night
most people if you break it down
why didn't they want to vote for trump
because he's racist and he hates trans
people that's literally what people
would say so until you're creating
narrative of these social issues
you're not going to win elections or
when people you know
when anyone's favor um obviously
i think a lot more was at stake in the
election
than trans issues or racial issues
but those are the issues that most
people their cap their capacity for
understanding
who they should vote for ends there it
doesn't go any further
if you go on the street and you ask
people i mean i'm a really big fan of um
like on the street videos where people
go and interview people i've done some
of them as well
um and those videos where people ask
people why are you not voting for trump
and it's like
well because he he did this to trans
people well he's racist
people don't think beyond that um so you
have to win the cultural world
and it's very interesting you say that
that you have to win the culture war
because people on the left are denying
that the culture will even exist
well they deny everything exists i mean
a very good example of that is like if
you say um
anytime you tweet you guys can test it
out if you tweet
that biological sex is real it'll be
nothing but
left-wing activists saying no one thinks
it's not real no one thinks it's not
real but yet you have
tons of activists going viral every day
for saying that it's not real
um they have double standards they like
to pretend things don't exist when they
exist
if they can't win on an issue they
ignore it which is kind of genius if you
ask me actually
um you know i think that is the mo
you're absolutely right
and do you think that we're ever going
to get out of this mess
because here's the thing blair maybe
it's because i'm getting old
but i i was remembering a time where
people were more civil to one another
we weren't at each other's throats we
weren't hyper partisan
do you ever do you think we can ever get
back to that place or do you think that
we're just progressing on the road to
hell as it were
right i mean i'm not that old i'm 27
but i am old but i also to remember
um a time where it wasn't like this at
all either
um and i guess what's scary is that
younger people don't remember that time
like people who were maybe
becoming teenagers or young adults um
around like 2014
2015 when there was kind of this shift
like i remember the shift
you know um they don't remember a time
where it wasn't like this and this is
just how they interact with other people
um so that's scary but i think that if
you look at history
the pendulum always swings um i think
people will get sick of what's happening
eventually um how long that'll take i
can't really say
but someday this is gonna sound really
nihilistic and dark
someday someday nothing will [ __ ]
matter like someday the world's just
gonna end
and like the sun's gonna fade out and
all this [ __ ] we're doing will not
[ __ ] matter so
maybe that's the day all this will be
over but hopefully it'll be sooner than
that
and you identified a shift between 2014
and 2015.
i find that very interesting we've
talked to many many people over the
cultural
i can't remember somebody saying that
what particular shift was there
and was it a particular event or
something you noticed as a general
so uh as a general rule i think
2015 trump announcing his candidacy
was definitely a moment because then you
saw
the media rallying against him you saw
the smears start and things just got
really nasty
the discourse got really nasty um people
began attacking each other in ways that
was seen as maybe uncouth or not
acceptable prior to that
um but there has been prior to that
there was a slow burn
of academic integrity that was happening
on college campuses
that's something that i experienced
and that was the subject of my first
video ever was my experience on college
campuses
i think it started there i think that
um in 2014 there just suddenly were more
activists than ever
in professor roles in colleges and um it
started in like gender studies classes
in my opinion
uh and eventually just kind of overtook
everything
and there was this weird not weird there
was this glorious time
where people were against labels and
against seeing people
in terms of groups and labels um is that
saying racism or sexism and all that was
over no
but i'd say it was pretty mitigated and
i would say that was like the mid 2000s
um where there was very much an
anti-label sort of movement
and then it went to the opposite around
2014 like i said i can't say exactly
like a a split moment but i think it was
just a slow burn that happened over time
um but i i missed the days when you
could just say stuff that you wanted to
say i missed the days when you didn't
view people who disagreed with you as
your mortal enemy i miss the days when
you could disagree with someone without
telling them to kill themselves um it's
it's sad and it's sad to see what people
are doing to each other
yeah it's a good point and it's the
reason we started the show and
by the way neither francis are
particularly on the right even but we do
find
increasingly that it's easier to have
honest and open conversations with
people who are
right-leaning at least and left-leaning
and that bothers me because
a lot of our values you might say are
somewhat on the left certainly by uk
standards anyway
but let me ask you this are you are you
optimistic for america because we kind
of from outside we see a lot of people
we talked about it before we started the
interview
people are now moving to states that
have the policies that they prefer
and that sort of alignment and you know
are you gonna have like 25 red states
all kind of bunched up
somewhere in the south and then uh 25
blue states on the coast so is that
what's going to happen here
am i optimistic
well that's a loaded question because i
feel like the last year and a half has
shown me that like literally anything
can [ __ ] happen i remember
you know yep like i don't know if you
guys feel the same way but like
january through mid-march of 2020 feels
like a different planet
like a different world like i i think of
like my life back then and it's like
speaking of a shift that was a shift i
never would have thought in a million
years of everything that happened
from you know i don't know what it was
like over there necessarily
but just the world being shut down and
just i remember being
in my apartment in hollywood overlooking
the walk of fame
and seeing tens of thousands of people
and military tanks and
cop cars on fire and just the craziest
[ __ ] i've ever seen and having to
evacuate where i live because
the world was just on fire um
so anything can happen but i am hopeful
that with now things reopening
people's mental health may be being
realigned a little bit
slowly but surely um i am hopeful
i think that we will persevere i just
think that it's going to be an ugly road
to get there and i think there's going
to have to be
a lot of reckoning of things that
maybe the left does not want to admit a
lot of the things we talked about here
today
a lot of those things they ignore rather
than argue about because they can't win
on it
um i'm i'm hopeful maybe it doesn't
sound like it but i guess i am
no it really doesn't no
everything's [ __ ] okay we'll see i'm
being
being english i'm very much appreciative
of that blair you're always welcome here
anytime you want we're all miserable
bastards so that that's just the english
way of looking at things
i mean i i i share your opinion
i mean do you think with everything that
happened
social media needs to take a lot more
responsibility for all of this
everything that we've seen
absolutely i think that man
it's hard for me to knock social media
for the simple fact that i've
i live like a really awesome life
because of it uh
in my real life but um
i think that it's done a lot to people
it's made people so quick to react to
things it's caused so much
misinformation it's caused people to
segregate even more um
you know one of the things that
i think social media has done is
it's caused people to not view other
people as people we're viewing people
with screen names reviewing people as
i as avatars and not as real people and
so i think that
it has affected the discourse in like
the political sphere of america in a
really ugly way
it's dictating the way in which
politicians here
you know lead um based on if they get
twitter backlash or not which i think is
really toxic and not a way to lead at
all
but it also brings to light a lot of
really important things so i think like
everything else in the human experience
it's like
it's the good and the bad and the ugly
and the beautiful and it's all mixed
together well this is what i think about
sometimes is like
if i could press a button and uninvent
twitter would i
and the truth is i wouldn't you'd need
about three new hobbies mate
exactly uh and and a lot of people i
could piss off with no consequence which
which isn't gonna happen anywhere else
uh blair listen it's been an absolute
pleasure chatting with you
um let us ask you our last question
before we do a couple for locals
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
hmm
[Music]
well my sphere of the internet is
talking about this but the mainstream is
not
the general public is not i think that
there is an extreme
i don't want to put anyone's mood down
but i think that there is an extreme
push
towards the sexualization and
normalization of pedophilia
um and i think that if that makes me a
conspiracy theorist in some people's
eyes that's fine because i think it's
real
i think more and more you're seeing
stories about really inappropriate texts
and videos being shown to kids in school
against their parents consent
you're seeing drag queen story hour
which was invented
by literal convicted pedophiles um
and all these things are being
normalized so i think that
it's almost the most important thing we
can talk about which is why it's become
a staple on my channel
um fighting against the normalization of
pedophiles
and right so let's get into this very
very thorny issue
so what particular examples could you
give blair
well i think that we've seen in recent
years
sort of a mobilization of pedophiles as
a community
and um a push to
destigmatize themselves by calling them
a politically correct term called maps
which is minor attracted people
um many people maybe don't know that
exists or that's a thing but it's a
thing i've chronicled it on my channel
you can watch videos on my channel about
that
um you have them trying to latch on to
the lgbt community which is
pretty [ __ ] up considering the lgbt
community have fought against
stereotypes of being predators and
pedophiles for decades
uh you know you have
sexuality and gender identity being
taught
at painfully young ages to kids and
in ways that are much more explicit than
ever i think that you know
for people my age and certainly you guys
age although i don't know how it is in
the uk i can speak for
you know the american school system the
way in which we were taught about
sexuality and reproduction was a very
sanitized sort of um method
through just seeing very technical terms
and scientific pictures and whatever
and now you're seeing kids in classrooms
watching videos
straight up about intercourse and about
sex and explicit
cartoons and um
you know i think that there is an
assault on
on kids right now in terms of
sexualizing them and i can't
if you ask me where exactly it's coming
from is there some power
that is pushing this or funding this
i can't name it i don't know but i know
that it's a thing
and it's uh pretty scary um well it's
good that you brought it up and uh
i'm sure that's something we'll we will
be paying even more attention to then i
think
you're not the first person to who said
this and and i think there's a lot of
truth
in what you say anyway blair we've got
to let you go uh we'll do a couple of
quick questions for locals so
uh before we do let you go uh just
remind everybody where they can find you
online
just search me up blair light on a new
platform i'm pretty much the only
blair white uh but youtube is my main
one so go subscribe to my youtube
youtube.com blair white x all one word
and there's an e at the end of blair
everyone forgets
fantastic blair thanks so much for
coming on the show and thank you all for
watching and listening at home uh we
will be back
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or raw show
and they always go out at 7 p.m uk time
or 2 p.m eastern standard time
take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below